♪ ♪
ANNOUNCER:
And now a special message
from the 45th and final
president of the United States.
Welcome
to the presidential response
to my presidential
State of the Union.
Here's my speech
about my speech.
I did it! I did it!
I read all the words as they
were put in the right order,
and I'd never even
seen them before.
Nobody can do that but me.
I'm not just America's leader.
I'm America's reader!
Tonight I made history.
I'm very proud to announce
that this is the first
State of the Union
to stream live on PornHub.
After every big performance,
I always run
to my dressing room.
Which is my plane!
I hide there and wait
for the reviews to come in.
And they're unanimous!
Tonight is the night I finally
became presidential again
for, like, the 17th time.
Everybody loved it.
It was so incredible.
Everyone was standing.
But I wish I was a Democrat
because they didn't have
to stand at all.
Did you see those guys
behind me-- Mike and Paul?
They look like the top
of a gay wedding cake.
But we both know
they're bottoms.
This is a new American moment.
Before I took office,
all our moments
were old and Australian.
They were all in the past.
And now, we're in the future,
and in the sky
where no one is underage.
Tonight I said we will no longer
allow immigrants
to exploit loopholes.
Exploiting loopholes
will be reserved
for real estate developers
like me.
I also announced
my four pillars of immigration,
and I'll announce them again.
Be white.
Don't not be white.
Have a marketable skill
like being white.
And Norway.
Oh, and Norbit!
That's the secret fifth pillar.
Wow! I remembered it!
MAUREEN: What are you...
what are you doing, sir?
I'm holding for applause,
Maureen.
MAUREEN:
Oh. Okay.
-Applause.
-Okay. Okay. Okay. -(clapping)
-Okay, that's enough, Maureen.
-Sorry.
-Save it.
-Sorry. -(clapping stops)
-Don't push it.
-Sorry, sir.
-Clap again, Maureen!
-All right. -(clapping)
She's an incredible welder.
♪ ♪